I think if women aren't victims how do  you have violence against women what  happens to all the organizations where  do they go and it's so bad that in I  just learned this the other day so I  might be butchering it but it's like in  33 States  um it's called oh my gosh there I can't  think of the name but there's like a  training system that they use that was  based on like it's for domestic violence  okay and there's three feminists that  came up with it who admitted it was  fraught like they admitted that like  because the  it basically said that women are  perpetually the victims and men are the  aggressors like that's the default and  the women that came up with this system  set in a college textbook that it wasn't  what they were seeing in real life but  they were so committed to this like  feminist ideology they implemented that  I think in the 80s right and so it's  like even in the in the court system  like they were literally trained with a  misandrist  um training system